[Musique]
la légende dit qu'il y a très longtemps
il y eu un terrible orage en Bretagne ce
qui finalement n'est pas un SC on dit
que les EAU de cet orage partirent au
fond de la terre année après année se
charg en colorant naturel et en new de
la caféine cristallisée qui fait un
effet à plus long terme et qui évite le
crashaéine qu'il y a éalement la gamme
classvec
éventail de goût et des antioxydants et
on dit également que quand l'eau
jaillira de la terre elle apportera paix
prospérité et la gamme hydration idéale
pour la récupération des sportifs après
l'effort grâce aux minéraux et aux
électrolytes qui évite les courbatures
oui c'est extrêmement précis et que
cette eau apporterait gaêé et longue vie
à quiconque la boirait mais attendez
j'ai pas du tout dit ça tais-toi
personne t'a demandé ton avis attention
olie n'apporte ni longue vie et ne
contient pas d'eau c'est à vous d'en
rajouter découvrez olit utilisez le code
JDG pour 10 % de réduction et jdg5 pour
5 € de réduction lors de votre première
commande le lien est en
description et maintenant retrouvons une
nouvelle histoire de papi grenier papi
papi coucou papi non les enfants vous
tombez bien tiens ça ça vous dirait une
petite partie de concorde c'est un jeu
vidéo ça vient juste de sortir j'espère
qu'il y aura pas trop de monde sur les
serveursin mais papi c'est déjà terminé
ce jeu quoi oh ah ça explique pourquoi
je l'ai eu à seulement 70 € en occasion
chez Micromania alors papi tu nous
racontes une histoire oh une histoire
est-ce que je vous ai déjà parlé de la
fois où je tabassais des animaux pour de
l'argent mais papi tu demandais pas
d'argent avant pour tabasser des animaux
c'est vrai mais j'avais tort hein quand
tu es bon dans un domaine faut jamais le
faire gratuitement c'était en 2000 15 et
à l'époque tout le monde m'appelait
guéralt de rive j'étais un sorceleur un
chasseur de monstres professionnel qui
parcour le monde pour accomplir des
contrats en échange d'argent êtes-vous
dérangé par des bruits de monstres au
milieu de la
nuit avez-vous déjà eu des noyeurs dans
votre
grenier vous êtes-vous déjà retrouvé né
àé face à une algoule une genaude ou un
é si c'est le cas n'attendez plus sortez
votre pigeon voyageur etelez
professionnel les witchers nos
spécialistes sont disponibles 24 heur
sur 24 là où les witchers passent les
spectres trépasse
osez parler nous sommes prêts à vous
croire mais papi comence à passer à la
télé si c'était à l'époque médiéval ben
on devait rejouer la scène à chaque fois
dans tous les villages cétait un peu
fatiguant on pouvait reconnaître un
Witcher facilement grâce à ces deux
épées on portait toujours sur nous une
épée en acier pour les humains et une
épée en argent pour les monstres et il
ne fallait pas que je me trompe sinon
c'était
inefficace tuas pas utilisé ton ép en
acier je suis toujours en vie je
parcourais le monde et les villages à la
recherche de travail je parlais aux gens
je chassais les monstres en échange de
quelques pièces du travail j'en manquait
pas faut dire que le coin était un peu
crgos bon et bien voilà petite maison
charmante authentique un peu dans son
jus mais la vue sur la rivière est
imprenable
est-ce que je vous ai montré la cuisine
ma principal c'était de récupérer Siri
que j'avais perdu de vue depuis des
années alors Siri ok c'est compliqué
alors bon alors en fait c'est ma fille
attends non c'est pas ma fille bon il y
a longtemps en gros j'ai gagné une
petite fille dans un cadeau surprise
laissez-moi finir ok après je la ramène
boire des couch che et des copains
attendez attendez il y a rien de malsin
elle a 8 ans on le faisait jouer au parc
là pour enfant celui qui peut te te te
tuer non mais moi je pouvais pas m'en
occuper moi j'étais en train de huiler
les fesses de yenfer oh et puis
merde tu fais quoi papi ben ça c'est
igni normalement c'est c'est en fait les
sceleurs on peut faire des signes c'est
de la magie et là vous devriez être en
train de de brûer vif tu es pas très
doué papi oui ben j'en ai un autre
celui-à il marche ti ça va ta
mère mais heureusement j'avais pas
besoin de maîtriser à la perfection les
sorts magiques car dans ma quête pour
retrouver Siri j'étais aidé par tris et
yenfer de sorcières des sorceleuses non
des sorcières vous êtes idiot ou quoi et
vous savez être sorceleur c'est
difficile il y a des inconvéniant par
exemple on perd la capacité de ressentir
les émotions comme la joie la tristesse
l'excitation suis-je donc condamné aéré
sur les Terres Maudites de nigard et à
être malheureux toute ma
vie quel fardeau que d'être un sorceleur
ouais ben ça va j'arrive oui mais papi
etessie de Siri alors oh écoutez Siri
c'est un problème complexe qui peut pas
être résolu si facilementin il faut
remonter en 1916 aux accords de Syx Pico
où les frontières du Moyen-Orient ont
été redéfini après la défaite de
l'Empire ottoman mais on n pas le temps
de parler de ça e vous pensez que TR
c'est une vraie rousse non parce que moi
comme j'étais occupé avec yfer j'ai
jamais trop eu l'occasion de regarder ça
papi oui donc Siri euh vous savez moi je
faisais pas que la chercher hein le plus
clair de mon temps c'était surtout vivre
des aventures et proposer mon aide aux
gens pour chasser les monstres
excusez-moi j'aurais pas besoin d'un
chasseur de monstre dans le
coin mais papi qu'est-ce qui t' arrivé
non rien rien rien c'est c'est naturel
c'était mon quotidien c'est les potions
qui faisaient ça les sorceleurs
concoctent toujours diverses potions
pour améliorer leurs capacités à partir
des ingrédients naturels que l'on peut
trouver dans la nature la nature est ses
trésors insoupçonnés chaque plante
murmure gardienne d'un savoir oublié un
éclat de vérité caché dans l'ombre
offert à qui sa'est regarder dans chaque
tige une histoire dans chaque feuille
une réponse qui la Sunrise vous en
voulez les enfants mais papi on parlait
des potions là alle ah non ça je les
acheté déjà fait ça casse les couilles
ramasser des P dans la nature j'ai pas
que ça à il y avait plein de
potions qu'on pouvait fabriquer ou
acheter des potions qui augmentent la
force des potions qui augmentent ton
endurance des potions qui te permettent
de voir la nuit comme la potion de chat
par exemple il y avait pas d'effet
secondair papi si un peual tuas encore
pris la chat c'est ça
il y avait aussi des potions de
phéromone d'ours comme ça les ours ils
m'attaquent pas quand je m'en
mets vous voulez pas savoir comment on
la fabrique celle-là ou aussi une
décotion de sucub qui augmente ma
vigueur lorsque je me tiens à côté d'une
femme étrange ça marche pas bon j'ai dû
rater la
potion bien sûr il fallait que je fasse
attention à ne pas trop m'empoisonner si
j'abusais des potions ça pouvait être
fatal heureusement il suffisait de
méditer un petit peu et l'empoisonnement
disparaissait
Géralt ça va oui oui ou ça va je je me
dites tu aurais pas des parchemins tant
que tu es là oui j'ai j'ai des
parchemins de sorcellerie phique de la
tour oui oui oui voilà ça c'est bien ça
je je te l'amène non non non ça çaer le
cercle de méditation dé jette de
moi j un
deuxième vas-y j'ai tout en
fait il y avait même des potions qui
agrandissaient la taille de l'vent
terire alors me demandez pas comment ça
marche mais en tout cas c'était super
pratique pour transporter mes six
chardonnés mes six camambber mes cinq
Pinot blancs mes vins rosés mes vins
rouges mes 31 autres bouteilles de vin
et mes 87 peintes de bière quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il y a arrêtez de me
regarder comme ça il fait froid dehors
mais sinon j'ai plein d'autres trucs
làdedans des testicules de troll des
cœurs humains des culottes ensorcelé
mais papi pourquoi tu transportes de la
merde ah oui oui j'ai de la merde aussi
oui tu en veux papi tu avais toujours
besoin de potion pour être fort ah non
non pas toujours non je pouvais aussi
modifier ma génétique par exemple en
absorbant des gênnes de monstres que je
tuais dans la nature
je sens que j' visis mieux l'arbalette
maintenant il faut sauver ta fille
geréralt tu as raison trce Siri est en
[Musique]
danger partiouette mais papi elle a
raison oui oui oui Siri Siri oui c'est
vrai oui alors je recherchais toujours
ma fille au milieu de tout ce bordel et
mes aventures m'emmenaient souvent à
fréquenter les plus hautes instances de
chaque royaume et leurs dirigeants
attention nous les sorceleurs avons fait
vœu de neutralité et de ne pas
interférer dans les affaires politiques
de chaque royaume mais papi tu attaquais
souvent des patrouilles de l'Empire non
ah non mais ça c'est pas de la politique
et quand tu as eu une audience avec
l'empereur pour servir de médiateur sur
l'avenir politique de tout le continent
je ne fais pas de
politique bon on a était où et quand
c'est toi qui a décidé qui était le
futur dirigeant du royaume de Skellig
ouais mais vous croyez que c'est moi qui
décide de tout les sorceleurs ne doivent
pas interférer je vous ai dit ah renez
le fuchia ça va être tendant cette année
et quand tu as fait une tentative
d'assassinat sur le roi de redania et
quand tu as fait un concours d'anecdote
avec l'empereur de nilgard je vous ai
dit je ne fais pas de politique cette
anecdote est fausse
ouais c'est vrai je voterai pour vous
s'il y avait des
élections je peux me rouler dans le
gazon mais bon après ça c'est des cas
particuliers la plupart du temps c'était
pas du tout ça mais du coup papi ça
ressemblait à quoi une quête classique
pour toi B je sais pas c'est les quêtes
ou il y a une femme qui te demande de
retrouver son mari qui a disparu je sais
pas j'avais l'impression de faire tout
le temps ça mais ces quêtes me
permettaient aussi de me servir de mes
sens surdéveloppés quasi surhumain des
sorceleurs qui nous permettaient de voir
les moindres détails de notre
[Musique]
environnement cet homme est
mort probablement parce qu'il a perdu
trop de sang
des feuilles il y a très certainement
des arbres quelque part dans cette
forêt une emprinte de
l'eau cet homme a peut-être
été tué par un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
L c'est l pris il reste plus qu'à donner
les résultats au clients et à prendre
l'argentz j'ai arraché son pied pour
vous prver qu'il est bien
ah oui il est mort en fait mais pourquoi
vous avez fait ça j'ai aussi pris une
main et le cœur au cas où si vous voulez
partager avec la famille c'est rigolo
regardez si on fait ça dira qu'il a
encore en
vie c'est
dégueulasse pourquoi vous pleurez
écoutez si ça vous va pas je peux aller
chercher un œil ou ses oreilles je les
ai laissé sur place j'ai pas enterré le
corps alors il y avait des loupes pas
loin faut laisser faire la nature quoi
écoutez c'est la pièce d'or ah oui il
faut bien
manger
bon partie de mais papi tu es horrible
non ça va je leur ais dit que les
sorcelurs ça ressem pas les émotions
merde et puis ça va aussi je voudrais
bien vous y voir avec 15 quê en même
temps à chaque fois votre mari est mort
quoi il coupe du Gois juste
là ah euh vous avez des frères des sœurs
non
d'accord bon je vous montre des têtes
coupées d'enfants et me dites comme vous
en reconnaissez une ok alors mais c'est
une culotte ça oui et elle est enchantée
enchanté bon tu es parti de gent papi
c'est quoi le gint dont tu parles tout
le temps non le gent c'était un jeu de
cartte très commun une vraie passion je
collectionnais les cartes je jouais avec
tout le monde dans les tavernes après
c'est vrai je dis pas peut-être que je
me laiss un petit peu trop emporté par
le jeu ma fille de 2 ans c'est fille
arraché la tête par un troll et ma femme
s idé de chagrin il y a un mois et ma
maison a brûlé la semaine dernière c'est
une partie de gent mais bon au moins ma
collection de gwiin personne m'emmerdait
avec pourquoi bah parce que avant de
jouer au gint je collectionnais les
cartes de j'allais dans les
auberges je couchais avec des catins et
puis je ramassais une carte
souvenir oh merde j'ai l' déjà SEP fois
celle-là et c'est là d'où est venu le
jeu des C famille je les ai toutes il me
manque que la grand-mère mais bon tant
pis de toute façon moi je préférais le
gint ah ça virait à l'obsession j'y
pensais tout le temps on veut tous être
le meilleur witchur et prouver de quoi
on est capable on veut tous tuer des
noyurs éviter toutes leurs entrailles
bah pleure pas bébé enfin bref après
avoir voyagé aux quatre coins du monde
j'ai fini par retrouver Siri et
apparemment elle était promise à un
ttien exceptionnel alors en gros elle
est d'cendant
selfique c'est la descendante d'une
sorcière je crois dans le tas il y a une
histoire de s ancien et de prophétie mes
fesses ah oui puis il y a aussi une
entité spectrale qui veut la capturer
pour utiliser ses pouvoirs parce que
aussi elle peut voyager entre les
dimensions oh pu ça fait chier voulez
pas une carte de gind là plutôt
ah merde c'est pas les bonnes on a fini
par vaincre la chasse sauvage et Siri a
passé le portail interdimensionnel pour
aller détruire le froid blanc dans un
autre monde en suivant la prophétie de
l'yline elle est morte oui le corps
humain est pas fait pour passer des
portails dimensionnels c'est pas fait
pour ça PAP écoutez attendez je vous
explique voyez notre espacetemp c'est un
peu comme cette feuille que je peux
plier et lesortail
c'est un peu comme ce stylo et là hop là
je l'encule bon de quoi on parler mais
papi c'est pas une histoire ça c'est un
jeu vidéo comment ça un jeu vidéo et ce
sac là rempli de mains coupé de pierché
il vient d'O PAP tu nous racontes une
autre histoire bien sûr mais ça sera
pour la prochaine fois
[Musique]